hay midgets!
How you feel to day?
[narrator]- On a summer's day in 1553 after ten days of traveling,
a magnificent procession reached the capitol.
At it's head was Mary Tudor, the eldest daughter of King Henry the Vlll.
She had come to claim her inheritance. The crown of England.
[David]- Mary entered the city of London in triumph on the third of august 1553.
The buildings of the city that Mary knew have disappeared
almost completely. But it's boundaries are the same
of the modern city of London's financial district you see behind me.
Mary entered from the east. At Aldgate and she rode through streets hung
with precious tapestries to the Tower of London
The people wept tears of joy and Mary quoted ecstatically from the bible
'If God be with us, who can be against us?'
[Narrator] This day was Mary's victory over all those who had opposed her.
But the joyful scenes were not to last.
Mary was a queen driven by conscience and by faith.
She would send hundreds of her subjects to burn at the stake for what she believed
was right. A vision of England restored to it's traditional Catholic faith.
Mary was born on the eighteenth of February 1516.
A Greenwich palace beside the River Thames.
She was given a splendid christening and the bells rand for joy.
[David]- The Princess Mary was an extraordinarily important child.
Her parents Henry the VIII and Catherine of Aragon had already been married for seven years
when she was born and they'd had several children.
but all the other children were either stillborn or they died shortly after birth.
Mary was the first child to survive.
This meant that she was heir to the crown of England.
There was only one drawback, Mary was a girl
and a woman had never ruled England as Queen.
Mary's destiny was clear. She was a royal princess
who will become a royal bride and only reign as her husband's wife.
The search for the right husband started earlier
*Sign of the Cross
Amen
When Mary was only two she was betrothed to the Dauphin, the heir to the throne
of France in a ceremony which mimicked all the features
of a royal wedding.
This was just the first of many engagements
Over the next ten years the promise of Mary's hand in marriage was repeatedly
used for treaties with other countries.
As daughter of King Henry and heir to the throne, Mary was an attractive proposition
But her mother's family was even grander
Catherine of Aragon was descendant of the great Spanish royal family
whose empire now stretched across Western Europe
and even to the new world of America.
Catherine made sure that Mary did not forget the Spanish roots
Mary spoke Spanish as well as English and proudly identified herself
with her Spanish family.
After her father the King, Mary was treated as the most important person
in England. She liked music, dancing, and games
Henry referred to her as his pearl in the world.
Catherine too was devoted to Mary who was fiercely ambitious for her daughter.
She made sure that Marys education would fit her for her destiney.
How ever great it might be.
David: this letter was written by Cathrine to Mary when she was age 8 or nine.